let me paint you a picture of the 4.7  million dollar account that I just  landed using social media only in a way  that nobody thinks about social media so  there was a CMO of a company I really  wanted to get to right and I have no  real angle  so I followed him on Twitter  and I didn't hit them up with a tweet  and say hey check me out I didn't do  that nope what I did was I listened and  I found out Scott that this guy is a  huge St Louis Cardinals fan but I  drafted Colton Wong second baseman of  the St Louis Cardinals on my fantasy  baseball team and I started talking to  him about Colton Wong  which made it very easy for him to look  at my profile and see that I was the CEO  of a social media agency at a time where  he was debating the value of his and  every person in this room could do it  but it takes patience it takes time it  takes being a great salesperson you know  what a great sales person is a listener